hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful and more fun right so
in this video let's find the area of a
triangle using matrices so in the
previous video I talked about how to use
the determinant how to find the
determinant of a matrix but here we're
going to do in this videos we're look at
applications of using the determinant
and in this case to find the area of a
triangle so here's the formula over here
it's plus or minus 1/2 and you can see
here's the vertices of the triangle x1
y1 that's point number 1 x2 y2 that's
point number 2 and x3 y3 that's point
number 3 in this third column we just
write 1 1 and 1 you can see the straight
bars which represents take the
determinant of the matrix and then you
can see here plus or minus 1/2 which
reminds us a lot of the 1/2 base times
height formula right for area of a
triangle but why the plus or minus well
if the determinant comes out to negative
okay a negative number you're going to
multiply by negative 1/2 okay if it
comes out to positive x positive 1/2 the
area of a triangle is always going to be
positive so just use the one that's
going to make that determinant positive
and then multiply by the 1/2 so let's
look at an example how to find the area
of a triangle with the given vertices
here 2 1 5 1 and 4 3 ok so let's go
ahead and do this problem we're going to
draw the determinant here just to show
you how this works okay so we have area
equals plus or minus 1/2 - 1 5 1 4 3 and
in this column I'm going to put 1 1 1
okay with me so far
all right good so what we're going to do
is we're just going to ignore this 1/2
for a moment and I'm going to show you
the technique that I used in the last
video of just taking this 3 by 3 matrix
and writing it right next to itself ok
just to do this in a quick and easy way
okay to find the determinant so we're
going to take the diagonal here we're
going to multiply that together we get 2
plus 4 times 1 times 1 which is 4 plus 5
times 3 times 1 which is 15 ok we're
going to add all those together which
is 6 plus 15 is 21 - we're going to take
the diagonals going up to the right this
way that's going to be 4 plus 3 times 1
times 2 which is 6 plus 1 times 5 times
1 which is 5 10 plus 5 is 15 so we're
subtracting 15 so this comes out to 6
okay so with me so far diagonals going
this way we multiply diagonals look
going up this way we multiply we add
each of those three together and then we
subtract okay so now we're going to
multiply by 1/2 positive 1/2 since this
came out to 6 and we get an area of 3
square units now let's see if this makes
sense we're going to go ahead and draw
this triangle in the coordinate plane so
we've got 2 1 1 2 1 okay we've got 5 1 3
4 5 1 and we've got 4 3 which is 2 3
right there so if I draw the triangle
okay you can see that this is 1 2 3 ok
so and you can see that the height is 1
2 and so the area of a triangle is 1/2
the base times the height so what do we
get 6 times 1/2 which is 3 which
corresponds with what we found here now
you might be saying well Mario I could
have just done that by trying the
triangle but think if you had a triangle
lose you know something kind of crazy
like that
you know maybe not so easy to find the
base here and maybe not so easy to find
you know the perpendicular height and so
on so I just did this as a simple
example to show you but if you have a
triangle that's maybe orientated in a
strange way in the coordinate plane this
can be a quick and easy way to find the
area so I hope you learned something in
this video go ahead and subscribe to the
channel check out some of the more
videos that I produced here talking
about other aspects of matrices and you
can see the link above and I'll talk to
you the next video I'll talk to you soon